اكثر شيء بخاف منه انه اني افقد حدا
يعني او انه اضلني انا في شقه وغاز في
[موسيقى]
شقه انا هيا عمري 26 سنه نزحنا من غزه
جينا هنا على خانيونس مع غازي تنقلنا من
مكان لمكان عبل جيت شويه هنا عنده ورحنا
على بيت ناس قرايب انا لحالي قاعده فيها
لبنت صغيره عمرها سنتين ونص يعني في اكيد
الاوبئه
والامراض وال الناس كلياتها مشتركه في في
الحمامات العامه
وفي يعني حتى النظافه اللي احنا لازم
نامها لو اولادنا مش موجوده انا من اول ما
بدات الحرب كنت في اخر الشهر الثامن وانا
موضوع
انه هي ممكن في اي وقت اولد كانت يعني
مخوفاني طول الوقت اخذت ادويتي معي
وعند مرحله معينه
وقفتها وغير انه يعني التعب لانه نومه
الارض والحمام اللي مثلا ابع
كثير معي بنت صغيره احمل فيها واتنقل فيها
من مكان لمكان وانا بينفعش اضلني احمل
فيها للبنت واروح واجي اكثر شي بخاف منه
انه اني افقد حدا
يعني او انه اضلني انا في شقه وغازي في
شقه
بس شي حسيت البنت كبرت اكثر اه طبعا لانه
هي بس تسمع صوت طياره انه تلبد في حضني
وتحط ايديها على دينيه بس تسمع صوت
الطياره بس انه هذا الشيء كثير يزعجني لما
كان كل شيء يكون موفر لها في يوم من
الايام كل شيء موفر لها وهي تطلب شيء ومش
قادرين نجيبه فهذا كثير كان الموضوع يحرق
قلبي يعني انه هي تطلب شغله وانا مش قادره
اعملها اياها او انه تطلب ترجع على البيت
تقول لي انا بدي سريري او بدي
اغراضي اقعد اعيط انا واياها طب هي من لسه
طفله عمرها سنتين ونص شو فهمها يعني احنا
قبل قبل فتره من الحرب كنا راجعين من من
السفر وكنا جايبين يعني قد ما احنا
مبسوطين على جايته انه جايبين كل شي بخص
البيبي يعني مبسوطين كثير في الاغراض يعني
كل يوم ارتب يعني كاني بستقبل البيبي
الاول مش البيبي
الثاني
[موسيقى]
كيف تقدري تفصلي
بين شغلك وبين مشاعرك تجاه اهلك انه لا
بدي اكون معكم ما بديش اطول كثير في الشغل
انا توته كثير بتحكي معي بتقول يا بابا
خلص بكفي شغل يعني هي متعوده انه لما بطلع
على الشغل بالايام العاديه بتقوللي تطولش
فانا الي اكثر من 30 يوم مش شايفهم
بتقول لي ما
تطولش بس مش قادر مش قادر اترك لانه واجبي
ومسؤوليتي بتقتي انه انا لازم اكون في
الميدان ولازم امارس عملي ولازم اكون
الصوره للعالم وانقلها
[موسيقى]
للعالم
ه